so you playing with the rays
so you went to the world series in no
way was you
i was not i went i was there for uh way
after that
but i remember that team and uh
i feel like that team kind of um leaned
a little bit on kind of like the money
ball right like as far as like
they did on the money ball um but they
um
we had joe madden you know what i'm
saying yeah legendary coach
belief system you know what i'm saying
like it wasn't even past the money but
it was just the whole
mindset you know what i'm saying i
didn't think nobody can really get into
my head like
that you know what i'm saying but he
came in and like got it best coach you
played with
yeah he probably the best one because
because because no matter how negative
you get
he would never let you get negative you
know what i'm saying
like for example i'll be you know mad
about something with a teammate i'll be
like y'all feel like this [ __ ]
i don't care well you know what i'm
saying and i'll be back
and i'll come back go on joe office
give it to him just like i told
everybody else he'll just bam let me get
it out right
just start breaking me down this and
that and but in the comments you know
you're not yelling right
and i'll just be like all right
she's gonna get some [ __ ] off your chest
i think that that's the weirdest sports
venue i've ever been to
tropicana field because you're in there
and it don't feel like you're
in a baseball game it feels like some it
feels like carnival or something
it feels like you're at a carnival
that's exactly what it feels like like
it's the state fair or something
like there's like there's some sort of
like gun convention going on down there
like
that was that that was had to be a weird
place to play i mean
you got used to it i'm sure you know
what i mean it's not going to be high in
this perfect temperature
and stuff like that because you really
appreciate that when you start playing
on like when i went to boston i was like
damn you know i'm used to the game
starting on time every day at seven
perfect and now i got this cold weather
and i'm just
you know uncomfortable all the time so
but